about a week and a half ago now there
was a wonderful event that took place in
New York City called the world science
festival and it was organized by the
university's inside the city of New York
and it had about 40 venues and and one
of those venues was in NY you and I had
the privilege of participating in it and
the venue was called future cities all
right how do I imagine the future city
if we can't learn how to make our lives
as comfortable as possible and recycle
by that by recycling I don't mean
collecting old tin cans and bottles and
crushing them up and selling them for
profit no no I mean behaving
ecologically to the point of conserving
all of the passive transfer of energy
that we have available with minimum use
off the grid and in fact add energy back
to the grid and become a grid have
cities become grids for energy
generation we manufacture we use and we
discard there's that's got to change all
right Cradle to Cradle not cradle to
grave that's the deal so I imagine
that's how everybody can get involved
every citizen can think of a way in
which something that we do this way
today is done differently tomorrow and I
know this day is coming because I feel
it deep inside now I have a little
saying on the side of my desk at work I
know this sounds corny it's from a
fortune cookie didn't say for a good
time call it didn't say that what it
said was nothing is impossible to a
willing heart now that sounds corny but
to be honest with you if you don't
believe it that it's this is real and
that that's actually going to change
something there's no way that you can
get somebody involved I have never had a
response to this program other than my
heart says this is a damn good idea
let's take it further and
intellectualize it and see where it goes
that's how you get involved you know
come up with your own strategy for
growing food inside the urban setting
but it has to reuse the energy that you
use to make it with to be
in with that's all that's the only
requirement after that you're on your
own